I turn to my right and see two friends
from the NFL media group here half of
the around the NFL podcast that has
become so popular at to our office up
the 405 here in Southern California Greg
Rosenthal and Kris Wessel and good to
see you here on the Richardson show
thanks for having us rich you got it you
were our first guest on the around the
NFL podcast do you know that more
episodes in is that right I did not and
more importantly I think with your sway
you got that sway yeah at the NFL
Network I mean you know now let's give
you got that studio built and you didn't
stay there doing the podcast there
forever but if it wasn't for you
building that studio I don't know I
don't know if we'd be here the podcast
out of which this show was born right um
I have not been in the studio in a very
long time is the Rich Eisen podcast
banner hanging from there in the same
way that Dion's banner is hanging in the
house that he built in Atlanta I think
it's mostly decorated by damage check
yeah Terrible Towel hanging 66 Jersey
Mario Lemieux well it's funny Dan Han
juice and Mark sessile are gonna be the
other two I shouldn't say that but the
two that rounds out the quartet they're
gonna be on the show next week and it's
funny on on vacation last week I just
texted you Greg to say hey can you how
about you guys come on and who you are
day one I mean we show us sure we're not
divas I know there's some other Daniel
Jeremiah for one I know that's true he's
tough try to give him a five-day letter
otherwise he uh you know he would never
be able to show up here okay so uh you
guys have watched an absurd amount of
preseason football
have you seen pretty much every snap of
preseason football so I'll say it away
on some of the fourth quarters and the
third quarters I and when it gets to be
a little too much semaj P Ryan and Ryan
Griffin you know these guys who never
see a snap in a regular season game
because they can't make the defender
miss or they just can't make the throws
right so that's when you realize you're
not watching NFL football anymore okay
so then what would you say cuz we are
obviously stuck in the helmets Zeke
Elliot vortex right now with Brown
what's the story of the preseason if
there
through the first two weeks Chris was
well I would say that Shawn McVeigh has
started this thing where nobody plays
their starters yeah so it's rare to see
actual NFL football in the preseason and
three or four years ago I don't think
that was the case you would still see
starting quarterbacks playing a full
half and now you'll see three or four
games in a row where you rarely see a
starter so does that mean we're gonna
see choppy play and weeks one and week
two I think we've already seen that the
last few years and maybe that's why the
offenses have been so far ahead of the
defenses to start the season because
you're not getting as much of the
hitting and the timing down on defense I
love that McVeigh did it makes a slight
our lives easier because it used to be a
little bit of week 1 week 2 and week 3
you really have to crank through all
that the rams didn't play any starters
last year and now there's about five or
six teams I think that are going that
route and even the teams that do play
the starters only for a quarter two and
if you look at kind of how the Rams it
at the Patriots a little bit last year
even week one they'll warm up into the
season by playing their guys 3040 snaps
I think it's the Sports Science guys in
the building if you look at the Jaguars
for instance who had a ton of injuries
they were the team that always did like
you know padded practices twice a day
going crazy now they're the total
opposite they don't play any other guys
in the preseason it so has anybody
flashed like for real though that you
think can have some school who's that I
was watching the Patriots game last
night and we make fun of Greg because
their fans sit on a throne of ease they
just keep getting better and better all
the time they got a guy in the third
round chase win of it I'm sure you've
watched him at Michigan who has a motor
of the likes of which you just don't see
this guy's Rambo he's up in the trees
he's in the cave he's down by the
riverbed you're looking for him every
play because the Titans want to get a
good look at Ryan Tannehill their fancy
new backup quarterback and win a vich is
single-handedly reckonin dismantling
their entire offense for a whole stretch
of the second quarter into the third
quarter
you finally get unblocked because here's
what guys are doing to chase winter
which after he beats their right tackle
and left tackle over and over again they
have a tight end suplex amour something
or the right tackle finally gets
frustrated and throws
you know picks him up and throws him
it's a holding penalty they finally get
done with that they block him special
teams he tracks down the returner this
guy is everywhere on the field well I
would look at you Brockman on your
throne of ease to use the Christmas Mary
comes I would say I would say I told you
so but then you you met wina vich when
he came here in studio and when he
walked out of here after he was on the
draft you were like okay let's get him
he's no joke I mean that was one of the
best preseason performances I've ever
seen for what it's worth I mean he like
took it over I every year I give out a
preseason MVP award and there's two
Patriots in the mix I mean we know it
wina [ __ ] and Jared Stidham they might
have found kind of their next Jimmy gee
they're the quarterback from Bob Robert
I believe the reporters that are at
practice that say he's far ahead of
where Jimmy G or Jacoby percent were
during their rookie years at the day he
showed up there he was more accurate
kind of more together and I think that's
what you can get out of the preseason
just seen which doesn't mean that
quarterbacks that struggle early are
gonna struggle forever but some that
know what they're doing right away and I
would throw Daniel Jones into that mix
who can change the play who can go to
their third read who can change tempo
Daniel Jones was doing that during the
second preseason game that like that's
next level and that means they'll
probably be playing sooner than later
that's Greg Rosenthal he's a part of me
sitting next to the Chris Wessling from
the around the NFL podcast right here on
the Rich Eisen show from the NFL Media
Group and in case you're wondering
Greg is in fact wearing a seersucker
sport coat I noticed I mean if I'm if
I'm gonna go my in-laws my father-in-law
lives in Japan if he's gonna buy me a
seersucker what better place to wear it
first and the relationship attaboy
I you know what we are the home of
seersucker and the radio television
simulcast world
I like that response rookie running
backs
give me one that you think that is gonna
be significant this year love David
Montgomery from the Bears everybody's on
that tree love that guy he just seems
like he was born to play running back I
know he's not say qualm Barkley as far
as freakish physical skills right but
his instincts his all-around game has a
to make people miss but still run you
over like maybe like slightly less tough
a little bit faster version of Eddie
George mmm that's significant I don't
think he's quite like I mean Eddie
George is probably the toughest running
back I've ever seen right so not quite
that tough but but a good all-around
back what about you Greg hmm I the one
that sticks out is I'm now even
forgetting his first name Thompson from
Kansas City I think Darwin Dom Thompson
from Kansas City who's like a
sixth-round pick I think is gonna get
Carlos Hyde cut off that team well I
mean I was talking about this with a
die-hard Kansas City Chiefs fan whose
name rhymes with sh Mon Street and you
know hi just seems like a total mismatch
there like if you don't run for four and
your name's not Travis Kelce then what
are you doing on that team right right
isn't that basically what it is and they
find these guys I mean Kareem hunt was
not someone that was highly thought of
necessarily coming out and just what
they did with Damian Williams it's a
great place to be a running back but
that's what you can see in the preseason
is the young running backs that have the
lateral quickness and he looks like
someone that's going to be a factor like
it wouldn't surprise me if he is there
starting and running back you know by
mid season or even before that or his
pee ends up having a monster year
because like Montgomery he's with a
coach that's gonna know how to use him
and they don't care what guys what round
the guy was drafted in like they might
give him 200 touches don't you feel like
this is a Nereid year finally after
Chris I mean it's it's it's because
every year is Andy Reid's here finally
this is gonna be Andy Reid's here that
sure was a Nereid year until the AFC
champion in their defense and blown it I
mean you got a guy a second-year
quarterback getting the MVP putting up
28 points in the fourth quarter against
the Patriots basically making the
Patriots defense fall apart at the end
of that game if they win a coin toss you
know they win the Super boy I think you
believe you believe mahomes can do it
again I mean and by that by that I mean
dominate because as you know the one of
the most adaptive
adaptive organisms in the history of
adaptive organisms is an NFL defense and
you give an entire coordinating staff
league-wide a year to study some film I
don't care how many times you throw with
your left hand when you're right handed
that's gonna be an issue you're not in
your head I always think of Dan Marino
when this subject comes up because if
you said in 1985 of course you know Dan
Marino's gonna throw for 50 touchdowns
you know right he's gonna throw for
6,000 yards you would have said yeah
sure and he never got better the thing
with you know marine he was one of the
greatest quarterbacks exactly never got
better but the thing with the chief says
they're so loaded they're just so loaded
with talent they're even more loaded
than last year they keep reloading and I
just love how the narrative has changed
there's sort of an evolution of Andy
Reed narrative a few years ago people
are still making fun of his time
management at the end of the game
correct and now half the league seems
like third Andy Reid disciples well you
got naggy you've got Petersen min by by
proxy Frank Reich I mean we could go
down the list here I mean defenses might
try to adjust but they're not Andy Reid
I mean Andy Reid is the most influential
offensive coach of this century I mean I
think he's the best offensive coach of
the century I don't think there's that
many people in the NFL that would
disagree with that and especially if you
look at the september/october that he's
had the last couple years whether it was
Alex Smith or the Holmes he's so far
ahead of the defenses because he spent
the offseason changing what he's gonna
do they're not gonna just show up and be
the same in the difference now is he has
mahomes who's you know one of the great
young quarterbacks we've seen what is
that list of the great offensive minds
this century what mike shanahan be up
there yeah sure I mean I mean that's
kind of last century Shaun McVeigh is
already there for me I got one for you
josh mcdaniels yeah yeah yeah and by
proxy Bill Belichick I'm serious here
that's the whole thing about this issue
and again maybe it's because I got to
spend two days with Bill Belichick on
the NFL 100 series that's coming this
fall
III I mean what this guy has done in the
amount of football that he has seen one
of the only people who can actually
match it in terms of the amount of
football that they have seen
this century is an T read write and
every single time they hit each other
with the exception of a week one to open
a season or something like that right I
mean and then there's T b12 if there is
no degrading of his abilities if father
time doesn't just suddenly pop up in
week seven out of nowhere and Soni
Michele can do what he's doing with the
rest of that offensive staff I don't
care if there's no Gronk I think he does
show up at any point it's tough to not
choose the Patriots in the AFC right now
I can't push back on that I mean we
doubt them all the time and every year
they're smarter than everyone else they
have that advantage you know I'm reading
this book on Earl Weaver from the 70s
attaboy Chris Wesley and just seeing the
similarities between him and Belichick
and they've crossed paths before so in
Baltimore is that right - the belt used
to work right outside of Earl Weaver's
office offense when he was marchibroda
'he's no one's ever brought up for a
waiver on this show come on by the way
we've we've talked Darrel Weaver before
cuz one of the greatest videos of all
time on YouTube is him getting ejected
from a game in Memorial Stadium and as
he is constantly going back and forth to
get yet one last piece of the umpire who
is ejecting him who's miked up and
hearing every last glorious Bluestreak
word that's coming out of Earl Weaver's
mouth you could see on the scoreboard
behind him it's the top of the first
[Laughter]
we're showing it right here right on the
screen how about that for you guys we
got it we got the video for you you can
see on the scoreboards screen it's 7:30
9 p.m. at night these are the games and
they started at 7:35 it's very fuzzy
Priya oh yeah you can see there's not
even it's just the the Tigers are in the
field the Tigers are at the plate and
there's we came to see how many outs er
there might be just one out he's getting
his piece of his mind that's interesting
that Belichick would have a history
obviously tell it checks like Forrest
Gump he's like a stopper that's I feel
bad for the the guys like Andy Reed who
I think is a hall-of-famer
the people how many titles would peyton
manning have or Tony Dungy it's just
Reed would have two or three by now and
people would talk about him like I mean
exactly you talk about the people who
try to win in the Jordan era to
the NBA you've got Chris Wessling and
I've got Chris Wessling and and Greg
Rosenthal from the around the NFL
podcast on on on the Rich Eisen show
right here so who's the NFC favorite
give me one Chris I think the Eagles at
the top of my head just they just on the
winch train huh
I saw it in 2017 you know we've seen it
before he was he was MVP if he doesn't
tear his ACL so I know we've seen it
happen and there they seem as deep on
both sides of the ball as any team in
the NFL the Eagles would have been mine
early in the offseason the problem is we
we our podcast is three times a week and
by the end of the offseason now we've
talked about it for so long that I'm
sick of everyone else picking the Eagles
and you just have to try to pick someone
else I think there's a group though and
I put the Vikings in there the Vikings
the Saints in the Rams where it wouldn't
be a surprise if any of those teams made
the Superbowl but the Vikings are the
one I feel like aren't getting as much
attention for whatever reason adding
Kubiak to that offense with a defense
that you can't really keep together that
long I mean the salary cap era but they
have and is that talented seem as prime
does any one another one of the best
offensive minds of the 21st century Gary
Kubiak who to me is a godsend for that
teams exactly what they needed what
about the Cowboys I would have said them
as my number one gonna get everyone's
son if it was their defensive line
wasn't so banged up if you asked me say
September 21st I'll probably say the
Cowboys they just seemed like a 12 win
team to me they do to me too
they can't handle success this has been
a theory I've had for 15 years and they
always make it true that they believe
their own hype Jerry Jones talks about
how great they are like they always
believe that the year after they were
good like the year after they were the 1
seed in the NFC they fell apart
basically every time they make the
playoffs the next year they fall apart
they haven't made the playoffs twice in
the in the last what 20 years title row
it's been a long time and I remember
last year something unique about Dallas
about Greg I hear you and I totally
understand why you would say that and
believe it but when Jerry Jones last
year acquired Amari Cooper
we all laughed for one literally there
really was where you you
I loved it yes you might be the only
person in America who did that not named
Jones I'm serious they were so hard to
watch without him that you could tell by
watching them they need something to
make this office go but a1 but a1 for
him was I think a lot of people it was
over pain right and like how crazy was
he like a fox and then when he said that
we can be like the Rams offense
everybody you left over there right
there I mean because it's absurd but
you've got deck and golf
you've got Gurley and Zeke you've got
Amari Cooper now with by the way they
they have Randall Cobb who the hell
knows what they're gonna look with him
Michael gallops looking good right and
then from the Rams offense from back in
the day Tavon Austin who'd Steven Jones
said was gonna get two dozen touches a
game which by the way math doesn't it
was a little bit fuzzy right there today
of Sean McVeigh is he now coaching the
Cowboys let's see what Kellen Moore
looks I love Kellen Moore okay so I'm
just saying every time everybody thinks
Jerry's shot himself in the foot and
right now him saying Zeke who and Mort
reporting that rocky nice to know the
agent of Zeke is not laughing Zeke's not
laughing I don't know maybe September
21st is when we should revisit this I
understand the skepticism surrounding
Jerry Jones comments about Tony Pollard
yes the rookie yes behind a paywall at
the athletic Wilma clay their senior VP
who's one of the best personnel men in
the business yes
raving about Tony Pollard this is not a
negotiation ploy that's behind a paywall
they love this guy so because it's
behind a paywall it wasn't planted I
think it's plant like it I like that
mindset alright so before I let you go
Greg Rosenthal and Chris Wessling three
times a week we can hear you with hands
of sand Sessler on on NFL media group
podcast which I can't believe we're
saying we were the first to plant the
flag many have years ago Congrats on
your success on all that stuff thank you
rich you got it
anything else I need to know from you
guys before I let you go we got fabs on
the show tomorrow he's bringing a trophy
that of a league where he didn't even
make the playoffs just
just if you don't want to ask the hard
question you could put it in my voice
just like ask him like how good is he
really at playing fantasy like he's a
good analyst I feel like I feel like no
you know a lot of leagues I feel like I
know how he would answer that question
with he would find he'd find the
disrespect in that well I was in 14
waves last year and I made the finals
and eight of them enough 13 with the
Bella Twins you don't hear about the
leagues he doesn't win fabs by the way
we should change our team named Michael
fabiana's rolodex and The Bella Twins
should be our avatar before I let you go
first overall pick in fantasy should be
I want to say alvin kamara okay you're
not afraid of the vulturing on the goal
line
no maybe it's more he's gonna get the
ball sometimes Taysom Hill is gonna
throw it into some guy I never even
heard of he's gonna score 12 touchdowns
if he stays healthy no matter what and
maybe more but great I didn't tell you
he's the best running back in the NFL
but I would agree and I would take him
first you like at that higher level and
Fantas just take the best player like
he's much better every GM would take him
over Christian McCaffrey so do it if
you're a fantasy on YouTube okay good to
have you here at Greg with two g's
Rosenthal and act Chris Wessling both of
you on Twitter thank you for being here
in person up the 405 for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app